Denver Broncos great is what I will call
him Terrell Davis how are you d what's
up rich yes indeed man getting ready for
the haul getting ready to see my buddy
Jin and of course Jack getting in as
well that's the rights of course obvious
how do I forget that before we get to
that I know I don't know my mind slipped
hey TD before we get to all that I know
you're a golfer you play golf right TD
okay have you ever heard of a golfer I'm
not sure you know I'm not sure of other
people okay well uh you know think they
got qualified a golfer can have you ever
have you ever had a hole-in-one I have
never had a hole-in-one
have you ever thought have you ever seen
have you ever witnessed a hole-in-one
I have I've seen three of them thrown
from some from non golfing amateurs and
I don't know how they've done it but
weirdest thing ever you could play golf
or I've been playing golf or what now
20-something years I've never gotten one
and I play with buddies who they can't
take off their rockers you know they're
shooting hundreds and all of a sudden
they get that one lucky swing and by
album did also I witnessed three I know
that TD and and I love how tell to foe
is using your testimonial as proof of
his vindication but saying I'm not
saying he but Mike's not saying he he
got a home when he's saying he got a
hole-in-one in the first swing he ever
took as a golfer have you ever seen oh
no no I was with you I was with you to
the details came out of that was your
first swing ever yeah the hole was the
same size though it's just it's a it's
still a cup it was four feet all right
well we're gonna hit this maybe maybe
the only thing with David Feherty when
it joins us shortly so let's let's talk
about Champ Bailey let's start with
champ TD and why you think he's a
first-ballot Hall of Fame worthy you
have the floor it yeah you know yeah I
checked with the University of Georgia
of course Maha I follow champ for a long
time and you know he was an athlete he
returned kicks in college he was a
xever the cornerback he was just a true
athlete now you know he kind of put him
up there with Deon where he can do it he
can do everything and so it wasn't a
surprise when he started playing and the
pros he went to Washington and started
off his career really well and then they
had a shocking trade between him and
Clinton Portis where he goes to Denver
and you know continuous teleplay you
know he's just been solid he's been you
know really really good for a very long
time and when I was locked down corners
as they call him guys that you don't
want to throw - very smart understands
concepts you know works really hard and
got great I think no just football
instincts and so you know then been
doing it for a very long time at a high
level so I think we know when his name
came up I think it was kind of a
no-brainer where chant goes in and you
know I think anybody had any pushback
about champion a first-ballot
hall-of-famer now I know I called you
after mr. B passed away and you told a
story about what he what he meant to you
what did he do for you I mean what what
what part of your maturation because I
know you you were thinking of quitting
over in Japan because of the way things
were panning out for you in your first
year with the Broncos I'm wondering what
he did for you to get you on that field
and successful TD what he did really was
it was a different purpose when you're
playing for somebody who you genuinely
care about it's like your parents where
you know if you let them down you feel
really bad if you know if you don't you
know do something and have success or
try to give them what they've been
looking for Pat's been searching for
Super Bowl for a long time obviously you
know and him and John and they've gotten
there but they never can get over the
hump and you know I remember losing to
Jacksonville in 1996 where we had we
were kind of the favorites there blown
out
and yeah I remember that yeah it was
game but we should have won a game and
you know there was a time where we
thought about we lost an opportunity to
win one but then you started thinking
about people you let down and Pat what
kind of the first one on the my leg man
we really let pat down you know we let
Mike Shanahan down we let Pat down and
that really when you have that inside of
you and you have an owner that you care
for and that's a friend I think you you
go the extra mile to make sure you try
to accomplish things that that he's
proud of and that that was kind of my
career with Pratt was you know I had an
older that you know I don't know I never
played for another team so I don't know
what it feels like to play for another
team but I can assure you I never
thought about it because I never had to
it was always about and this is a great
place I've heard of people who came to
Denver from other other teams and talked
about their experiences with their
owners and and you know the environment
that was created there this environment
in Denver was just one of first-class it
was all the reflection of what Pat put
into it he never wanted any credit for
anything but he was just a cool human
being and that's uh that to me is like
one of the biggest compliment I can give
somebody it's just he was a great person
and human being and you know and was
just was what was about everybody else
but himself and no you know obviously
you know we're product is going in
unfortunately and I would've loved to
have seen him a witness this and
experienced this adventure of going on
that stage and uh presenting his Hall of
Fame speech but I'm sure he's looking
now and we just go celebrate his life
you know this weekend and you know it's
gonna be fun Bronco country's gonna be
too thick so it's gonna be really really
fun absolutely because then they were
gonna be there no doubt for the game the
night before Terrell Davis joining me
here in the Rich Eisen show I've never
asked you this question so it's
interesting I'm gonna do it on live TV
and radio is the reason why you showed
up and you know is pep only reason why
he showed up at the NFL Network yes yes
indeed yes indeed yeah right yeah but
he's want a guy with a job there
so yeah you know because he was on the
committee he was uh partly you know he
was pushing there you know front now
work and he would come down we would see
I remember he would come to this to the
set like yeah often and yeah so yeah a
you remember that huh oh yeah
now I kind of put two and two together
he was the first owner to show up at our
at our complex I put that in quotes now
it's a complex before it was just an
office across across the way from a
studio right you know so he was the
first to show up there first to say I'll
appear first to say you know what I'll
put my team on Thursday Night Football
and I'll put him on the road I'll put
him in Kansas City you know and and he
was the first to do all of that so it
doesn't surprise me where it's just like
you know you're you're beginning to
wonder if your playing career is over
and you might want to try TV and he's
like mom why you stopped by the NFL
Network yep
that's out rolled out man so again and
that just goes back to who he was he was
he would he would just do things just to
help other people and you know for me
personally like I said doing the Super
Bowl it was in San Diego and of course
you know I got tons of family their
friends and and I and you know relatives
whatever and so you know I went to pat
hose like in a house I know I needed a
lot of tickets and I wouldn't sure if I
can get them so what the Padnos like hey
man I need though if you tickets and you
know he asked me I mean I did I need I
gave him a number that was I didn't
think he would say yes to and he was
like no problem I got you oh that's cool
I was everything all my friends all my
family did super-boeing you know he was
the first one to call me when I tore my
ACL and had to meet I mean I go back to
that moment because that you know when I
woke up from surgery when I told mine in
1999 you know you get a phone call from
the owners the first one that the first
voice I hear is from him you know like
when I when I come come to his uh I just
kind of just reinforce who he was as a
person in our relationship and what we
had and he had a special knack for
making people feel as if they they were
if they were his favorite and and that's
what that that is something that you
know that's a skill and it's something
that I that I don't know if you can
learn that and and so that was really
good a good at that
Terrell Davis Pro Football Hall of Famer
getting set to bringing both Champ
Bailey and Pat Bowlen into the room
where he his bust resides forevermore
and can't know how
a couple more minutes left with Utd
alright last year you did something for
me and I didn't realize it at the time
you told me about this kid Phillip
Lindsey and to keep an eye out for him
and my buddy and Chris and I we didn't
jump on him on a fantasy league or a
waiver wire and I got a jump on this so
dumb won it rich give me another one
this year I'm have no idea what's gonna
look like Flacco's they're obviously you
know Emanuel Sanders coming off of
Achilles no Demaryius Thomas there
anymore
what in the world is this often it's
gonna look like give me a name give me
somebody to look out for oh yeah you
know right now there's a lot of there's
not a hope I guess you can use that word
hope because it's not a now there's not
a lot of knowing what that office is
gonna look like you assume you got there
their offensive coordinator Rick
scangarelo came from San Francisco
quarterbacks coach it kind of had an
offers in a cow Shanahan a Gary Kubiak
so it's kind of going full circle with
Joe Flacco and bringing in the offense
where yeah success with 2014 in
Baltimore and you can see some of it you
know it's a bootlegs it's you know it's
that play-action pass is this the run
zone stuff a little bit of the office
that I ran but they're young you know
around Flacco they're a young group you
got Phillip Lindsey it was a written
last year second year player royce
freeman second year player they shot
helmet in second year player Courtland
Sutton they're all second year players
and so you have this young young young
offense but you got a veteran
quarterback and Joe Flacco
no offense they drafted from Iowa so
they've got pieces but you know I think
it's kind of like hey how fast can these
guys get up to speed and and really
learn and master this offense because it
really it's a complicated office not
simple and you know I think that's gonna
take some time to get there and so I
don't think a lot of people have a lot
of belief that the Broncos are going to
be a factor this year but it can happen
you know their defense with Vic Fangio
and you know with Chubb and von Miller's
those two guys they've got to book in
pieces or secondary claims action they
got from Houston so you know they're
they're really and still got Chris
Harris out so they these
I know they're gonna be really good that
big Fangio's defense always sometimes
five top ten defense so that's not the
question is this the often so what do
they look like and it still working
progress and I was out there a week ago
and the defense was just they kind of
dominated them so you gotta say that's
going to be a evolution of an offense
and if they can get some things together
get some momentum get some you know get
some wins and you know maybe get a win
or two that they're not supposed to win
you know anything happened but right now
Richard they're pretty young and I don't
think a lot of people have high
expectations so draft the Broncos
defense is what you're telling me you
don't got what you don't have one for me
on the offense but the Broncos defense
special teams go and hop on them with
Vic Fangio and Coby Waldman the the
punter right let's get the punter in
there you know you reverse field and
then let the defense go to work get
Flacco a short field touchdown that's
what I'm saying TD you know you go you
got your bases covered I see that
already see in Canada see and tantor oh
that's it Terrell Davis four more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app